Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Wie hältst du's mit dem Krokodil?
Das Krokodil macht alle äh verrückt und äh entmutigt allen Teilen. Vielleicht sogar auch die äh SPD Mitglieder. Wer weiß.
Wann äh müssen sie nochmal abstimmen, an welchem Tag ist das?
Das müsste jetzt so die Tage vonstatten gehen.
War das nicht irgendein Dezember mit einer zweistelligen Zahl an Tagen?
Ja, jetzt wo du's sagst, kannst sogar noch zwei Wochen dauern.
Ich äh mal gucken hier. Ich habe ja so einen Artikel auf im Dezember,
Sechster Dezember, alle SPD-Mitglieder bekommen die Briefwahlunterlagen zugesandt. Neunter Dezember, ein kleiner CDU Parteitag soll in Berlin über den Vertrag abstimmen. Zwölfter Dezember, Einsendeschluss, vierzehnter September. Äh Stimmzettelauszählung,
Dezember, ja. Äh und siebzehnter Dezember,
Sollten die SPD-Mitglieder für eine Koalition mit der Union stimmen, könnte der Bundestag Angela Merkel mit den Stimmen von Union und SPD erneut zur Bundeskanzlerin wählen, ja? Also vierzehnter September Dezember ist die äh Auszählung der Stimmen.
Ja, die hoffen auf äh schöne Weihnachten.
Vierhundertvierundsiebzigtausendachthundertzwanzig Genossen gibt's noch und an denen hängt es jetzt.
Vierhundertvierundsiebzigtausend.
Will man nicht meinen, ne? Wie viele da noch austreten müssen, bis er keiner mehr drin ist,
Ja, die haben ursprünglich mal über eine Million gehabt, ne?
Die Zeiten sind vorbei und ich glaube jetzt auch nicht unbedingt, dass die aktuelle äh Gemengelage dazu beiträgt, ihnen einen Mitgliederzuwachs ähm zu bescheren,
Also seien wir realistisch, sie werden trotzdem ja sagen, oder? Weil aus so einer einfachen Logik heraus mit
Ja, wenn wir jetzt nicht ja sagen zu diesem Kompromiss, dann äh verlieren wir unseren Vorsitzenden, den wir gerade mit sechsundneunzig Prozent oder so äh wiedergewählt haben, weil die dann alle zurücktreten müssen
und das ist ja ganz furchtbar und da sind wir ja überhaupt zu nichts mehr äh gut so und wer soll denn dann Bundeskanzler werden?
Also Gabriel, Gabriel sagte, in einer Rede, was ich sehr interessant fand, es gibt keine Alternative zur Großen Koalition, sogar die Große Koalition ist inzwischen alternativlos, ja?
Für eine rot grün rotes Bündnis müsse
Linke erst ihr Verhältnis zur SPD klären, was ja echt ein Witz ist, ja? Als wenn die Linke ihr Verhältnis zur SPD klären müsste, so die SPD ist ja die, die die ganze Zeit auf die Linke einschlagen und
äh versuchen da, na ja, also gut. Und eine schwarz-grüne Koalition würde ähm natürlich heißen, dass der SPD, der strategische äh Partner auf Jahre verloren ist, weil die
Grünen natürlich dann möglicherweise, also natürlich am Status quo interessiert sind und weiter mit der CDU machen wollen, ja?
Und außerdem sagt er, ja, Minderheitsregierung sieht ja auch nicht. Und Neuwahlen würden die SPD finanziell und politisch äh ruinieren.
Warnt, wie diese Übergabe. Was willst du dazu noch sagen? Also jetzt, also wenn man's schon aus aus Geld man also,
Ich kann da, was soll ich da noch zu sagen? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich ich,
Komm, sollen wir uns mal mit dem Koalitionsvertrag kurz auseinandersetzen? Also.
Es ist wirklich absurd, ja? Ich meine, die einzige Partei, die irgendwie in allen Konstellationen äh Regierungsbeteiligung hätte, außer jetzt vielleicht schwarz-grün. Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt realistisch wäre. Also angenommen, die SPD würde jetzt nein sagen,
Glaubst du, dass die äh Merkel nochmal bei den Grünen anrufen würde? Ich meine, die Grünen, die würden doch noch mehr zusammenbrechen unter so einer Koalition. Ich meine, jetzt in Hessen, da haben sie jetzt mal so ihr Testbett, was sie da äh ernsthaft starten wollen, was auch absurd ist, ja, also wirklich so die,
gerade die CDU Hessen so, ja, dieser dieser dieser krasse äh äh Rechtsausleger, die auch wirklich die immer die unsympathischsten Ministerpräsidenten hervorbringen, ja, die man sich immer irgendwie vorstellen kann.
Und die dann irgendwie sogar noch mit so ausländerfeindlichen Sprüchen gegen diesen Chef von den Grünen irgendwie vorgegangen ist im Wahlkampf, also nicht in diesem, aber im letzten,
die setzen sich jetzt irgendwie an einen Tisch und wollen den Rigio machen. Das ist schon ein bisschen albern. Auf der anderen Seite kann ich das auch nur sehr begrüßen, weil das natürlich auch so eine Normalisierung ist, weil diese Selbstverständlichkeit, dass wenn jetzt irgendwie
Die beiden großen Parteien, ja, die im Prinzip auch so,
eigentlich so ein bisschen die Rolle der, der, der, der ewigen Antagonisten äh stellen sollt, ja, so nach dem Motto, entweder wir entscheiden uns für die Führung dieser Volkspartei oder wir entscheiden uns für die Führung jener Erfolgspartei, ja?
Und jetzt tun sie irgendwie so, ja, wir sind ja so durcheinander und wir können ja eigentlich nur zusammen.
Ja, ihr seid irgendwie achtzig Prozent. Ah, ist halt so. Das ist einfach, da ist weiß nicht, es funktioniert irgendwie nicht.
Wir werden sehen, was die äh was die SPD-Mitglieder machen. Interessante, also es gibt ja auch viel Kritik an dieser an diesem Mitgliederentscheid, ne, wo dann, wo da gesagt wird, ey, Moment mal, ich habe hier Abgeordnete gewählt, ähm,
wieso haben da auf einmal irgendwelche Mitglieder was zu melden, ne? Na, weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie man das äh ähm,
Und ob das jetzt eine Rolle spielt oder nicht, ne.
Wie beim Piraten.
Ja, genau, also plötzlich können Parteimitglieder irgendwas sagen. Ich weiß es, das ist ein ist ein Argument, ich wollte das nur kurz vorbringen, also naja, auf jeden Fall haben sie jetzt in den letzten Tagen ihren ihren Koalitionsvertrag da ausgehandelt,
Und ähm ich muss jetzt dazu sagen, ich werde da jetzt
zwei, drei Sachen aus dem Ding noch kurz rauspicken. Ich habe aber jetzt irgendwie in den letzten Wochen, glaube ich, drei Entwürfe davon gelesen
und bin selber jetzt einfach nur noch durcheinander was wo drin steht und was nicht. Deswegen werde ich jetzt nur zwei Sachen ernsthaft behandeln und ansonsten schauen wir, ob das Ding überhaupt abgesegnet wird, bevor wir uns damit weiter auseinander.
Ja. Dann können wir immer noch anfangen zu weinen.
In der Präambel netzpolitisch sehr wichtig, das Internet und die digitalen Technologien sind heute unverzichtbar und Wachstumstreiber für unser Land
damit jeder in unserem Land die Vorteile des schnellen Internets nutzen kann, wollen wir es bis zweitausendachtzehn flächendeckend in allen Teilen unseres Landes verfügbar machen
Netzneutralität sichern wir. In den Städten wollen wir außerdem die Voraussetzungen für kostenlose WLAN Angebote schaffen. Wir wollen die Chancen auf Innovation, Fortschritt und neue Beschäftigung nutzen und Deutschland zum führenden digitalen Standort in Europa,
wenige Seiten später äh steht dann eigentlich drin so, ja Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Richtlinie setzen wir um,
Schön ohne Einschränkungen, sechs Monate Vorratsdatenspeicherung, herzlichen Glückwunsch und auf EU-Ebene werden wir uns dafür einsetzen, die Mindestspeicherfrist auf drei Monate herunterzufügen, ja? Das ist,
Das heißt
übersetzt so, es gibt sechs Monate Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Dann wird irgendein Hanse mal in in Brüssel sagen, ja, könnte man nicht drei Monate machen, dann wird irgendeiner sagen, nein und dann ist der Koalitionsvertrag erfüllt, weil man hat sich ja dafür eingesetzt.
So viel zum Thema Vorzeitenspeichung. Äh nicht überraschend ähm.
Ich frage mich einfach nur, was jetzt bitte dann eigentlich anders sein soll als das, äh womit äh das Bundesverfassungsgericht die Vorratsdatenspeicherung bereits abgelehnt hat.
Da bin ich ähm mir relativ, also das weiß ich auch nicht, da lasse ich mich überraschen. Ich bin mir aber relativ sicher, dass die letzten Jahre nicht vergangen sind, ohne dass man sich darüber unterhalten hat. Da werden,
an ihren Weg sich überlegt haben.
Sagen, wenn es eigentlich mit der Entscheidung des Verfassungsgerichts auf Basis der aktuellen Verfassung nicht möglich ist, das durchzubringen und man fordert immer noch dasselbe.
Man ist jetzt gerade eine große Koalition.
Und hatte achtzig Prozent, dann könnte man ja vielleicht mal die Verfassung ändern.
Dass ich, also weiß ich nicht, ob sie so weit gehen, aber ja, also.
Ja, aber ich meine, dass ich sage nicht, ich finde jetzt nicht so weit gehend zu sagen, es droht, aber es ist möglich,
So und ich weiß auch nicht so ganz genau, was sie da letzten Endes dann in der Verfassung,
ändern wollen, damit es möglich ist, also ich habe jetzt nicht mehr so in Erinnerung auf welcher Basis das Bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich ähm.
Sozusagen zu dem Schluss gekommen ist, dass das nicht geht. So, aber unter Umständen wollen wir uns hier auch noch an die elementaren Freiheitsrechte und sozusagen äh alles ein bisschen mit das nähere regelt einem Bundesgesetz äh zupflastern.
Wird mich nicht wundern,
Aber äh wie gesagt, lassen wir mal, also da steht drin, das steht äh am vierzehnten Dezember auf dem Spiel. War aber auch klar,
Schönen Gruß an alle, die sich über den Rauswurf der FDP so sehr gefreut haben. Das habe ich ja damals schon vor so im September oder wann das Wahlergebnis war, gesagt, ist keine Überraschung,
Ähm toll, dass dass die Zahl drei da überhaupt noch drin geblieben ist, da kann sich die SPD jetzt wirklich richtig äh stolz äh was an an die Brust heften.
Wer hat uns verraten? Die Vorratsdaten.
Ähm,
Netzneutralität haben wir letztendlich einen sehr interessanten Absatz. Der sagt, der der Erhalt des offenen und freien Internets. Die Sicherung von Teilhabe, Meinungsvielfalt, Innovation,
und fairer Wettbewerb sind zentrale Ziele der digitalen Agenda. Der diskriminierungsfreie Transport aller Datenpakete im Internet ist die Grundlage dafür.
Ja? Dabei ist insbesondere auch sicherzustellen, dass Provider ihre eigenen inhaltlichen Angebote und Partnerangebote
nicht durch höhere Datenvolumin, voluminar oder schnellere Übertragungsgeschwindigkeiten im Wettbewerb bevorzugen. So, das,
Klingt nach einer sehr vernünftigen ähm Definition von Netzneutralität. Ähm.
Aber,
Was so, wie gesagt, immer noch äh also es könnte natürlich wieder so, sie reden da ja noch vom Internet und sie inzwischen wird ja auch der Spin gefahren, das managed äh Services eben kein Internet sind.
Mhm.
Und ähm somit, da wäre also nach wie vor diese diese Möglichkeit drin, das äh zu umgehen.
Und ähm später findet sich dann noch der Satz,
Die Gewährleistung von Netzneutralität wird daher als eines der Regulierungsziele,
Im Telekommunikationsgesetz verbindlich verankert. Und die Koalition wird sich auch auf europäischer Ebene für die gesetzliche Verankerung von Netzneutralität einsetzen,
Allerdings ist auch dieser Satz drin geblieben, dass äh dass man Einschränkungen im Voice-OV gegen Bezahlung ermöglichen muss, was ja wiederum die genaue ähm Verletzung von Netzneutralität sichert. Ich glaube,
Hier ist es noch zu früh, um da jetzt ein Urteil drüberzufällen, ja? Lass uns abwarten, was sie da am Ende machen,
Und dann können wir's sehen. Ne? Uns wurde eine Netzneutralität versprochen, werden wir mal sehen, welche äh wir dann am Ende bekommen,
Was ich ähm.
Niemand hat die Absicht, die Netzneutralität einzuschränken.
Was was ich sehr schön fand, also beim dritten Entwurf, da habe ich ja, da habe ich ja einen Kusselkorb gemacht, als der dann auf äh Zeit online live behandelt wurde.
Was hast du gemacht?
Ein Kusselkopf also so.
Nee. Kusselkopf.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab's noch nie gehört.
Ich muss jetzt ist doch ein Wort.
Seit wann? In welcher Gegend? Wo kommst du eigentlich her?
Also es ist in der Tat findet man da jetzt nicht so direkt ein Wikipedia-Eintrag zu. Ein, wie nennt man's, eine Rolle vorwärts? So.
Ah, doch, hier. Eine Rolle beim Turnen. Purzelbaum.
Ein Purzelbaum, ein Purzelbaum habe ich geschlagen, denn,
Er stand dann drin, wir werden die Weiterentwicklung von d dahingehend forcieren,
das bestehende Sicherheitslücken bei der Verschlüsselung geschlossen werden und dieses Angebot damit für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger ein geeignetes Mittel der Datenübertragung wird. Das heißt, nachdem ich,
zweimal in diesen Ausschüssen war,
Beide Male mir dann nachher im Fahrstuhl ungefähr gesagt wurde, ja wir wissen ja, dass sie Recht haben, aber ähm.
Wir machen das anders.
Wir machen das anders. Steht am Ende im Koalitionsvertrag dokumentiert, dass es bestehende Sicherheitslücken bei D-Mail gibt,
nachdem es ja drei Gesetze nachdem drei Gesetze geschrieben wurden, wo drin stand es gibt keine Folgendes, ist keine Sicherheitslücke bei D-Mail, ja, sobald Sovania, so war das ja, ihr lacht und ähm,
da habe ich gedacht, boah, das wäre jetzt ein, ein, ein, ein später
eine eine späte Genugtuung, ja? So, ich meine, ich hätte, ich habe nie erwartet, dass ich da was ausrichte und wenn jetzt dieser Satz da geschrieben ist, weiß ich ja auch nicht, ob er auf mich zurück
geht, aber es trotzdem wäre es natürlich irgendwie eine eine schöne, späte Genugtuung, am Ende sagen zu können, hier.
Koalitionsvertrag enthält auch eine sogenannte minus Neumannklausel.
Keine Ahnung, aber so das haben wir, da war ich ja auch nicht der Einzige, ich war jetzt derjenige, der den das da dann am am Ende nochmal in den Ausschüssen erklärt hat, da da musste man jetzt nicht ähm besonders klug für sein, um.
Okay, darf als unsicher bezeichnet werden, weil steht ja im Koalitionsvertrag, sage ich mal.
Nein, nicht nur darf als uns hier bezeichnet werden, sondern steht bestehende Sicherheitslücken an Eck, also wird anerkannt, dass das Ding Sicherheitslücken hat.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist das erste Mal, dass wir irgendwas anerkannt wird. So, also im Gesetz haben waren sie nicht bereit, es anzuerkennen.
Moment, das war ja auch nur im dritten Entwurf. Im Finale steht's nicht mehr drin.
Ach so.
Das meine ich, das geht so hin und her.
Okay, verstehe.
Das steht jetzt nur noch irgendwie sowas drin, wie äh,
zur Wahrung der technologischen Souveränität fördern wir den Einsatz national entwickelter IT-Sicherheitstechnologien bei den Bürgern und Bürgern,
Bürgerinnen und Bürger, das war nie anders, genau das äh ist ja dieser Demelkram, ja, zu sagen, okay, wir machen eine nationale Sicherheitsstrategie,
und auch wenn sie von einer Firma äh entwickelt wurde, die von der NSA äh beauftragt wird. Na ja, das ist ein anderes Thema. Ähm da wird's dann beim Kongress wahrscheinlich noch einiges zu erzählen geben. Ähm.
Und selbst jetzt, das Spannende ist, dann waren dann natürlich so die diese,
Bürgerrechtsthematik, die da jetzt nicht besonders äh groß geschrieben wurde bei diesem Koalitionsvertrag. Äh war denn
für natürlich die äh einschlägigen Kommentatoren ein Thema. Interessant ist das auch die äh der Koalitionsvertrag für die digitale Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft nicht der große Wurf ist wie der Bitcom Präsident Dieter Kempf,
ähm sich äußert. Ähm nämlich die vermissen hauptsächlich, dass ihnen zu wenig Förderungen für den,
Für den Breitbandausbau zugesichert wurde,
Sagen also, na ja, wenn da steht, bis äh zwanzig achtzehn soll überall Internet sein in, in, in, in guten Geschwindigkeiten, dann äh wollen wir natürlich auch schöne äh Subventionen dafür haben, dass wir das machen. Das steht da nicht drin und deswegen,
wundern wir uns, wie die große Koalition das denn erreichen möchte, wenn sie uns nicht noch mehr Geld irgendwie gibt, um das auch zu tun, weil wir haben ja keinen Bock darauf, äh Netzausbau zu betreiben.
Ja, vielleicht könnte man ihn einfach die Wege rechter entziehen und sie dem Staat übertragen. Hm? Groß Provider enteignen.
Also lass uns mal abwarten, was äh so passiert in Sachen ähm,
GroKo, ja, übrigens, ach war dir aufgefallen, dass der, der, der Name, Krokodil ja jetzt diesen Koalitionsvertrag bezeichnet, ne, aber Deal mit EA geschrieben.
Ach, der GroKo-Deal. Nee, wo soll ich das gesehen haben?
Grokodeal. Ja, weiß ich nicht, Internet. Internet. Zeit online und.
Internet. Hm, da bin ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen, da zu gucken.
Warten wir mal ab, welches Unheil äh äh für welches Unheil sich die die SPD-Basis entscheidet. Und was dann am Ende dabei rauskommt. Ich finde es also Koalitionsverträge ja
ne, kann man ja dann nachher sehen, was, also da sieht man schon die Stoßrichtung
am Ende äh ist das Handeln der der äh Genossinnen, Genossen und und Kameraden und Kameradinnen ja doch sehr viel durch das des Tagespolitische Geschehen bestimmt und dadurch wann was opportun ist,
Also werden wir mal sehen. Offensichtlich äh aber in einem Koalitionsvertrag ist ihnen nicht legen sie nicht besonders viel Wert darauf, was opportun ist, denn,
eine, also einen Ausbeute oder eine Implementierung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu beschließen. Im, in einer Zeit, äh,
NSA-Skandals, ja.
Das ist einfach schon mal ein Skandal für sich. Also es ist wirklich auch nichts gelernt und es bestätigt auch, sagen wir mal, diese grundsätzlichen Vorbehalte,
glaube ich, die wir gegenüber den großen Parteien hier schon über die Jahre immer wieder geäußert haben, ja. Es gibt ja dann immer wieder so diese äh
sagen, sozialbewegten SPD-Mitglieder auch im Netz sind immer so, ja, man muss da ja auch mal drauf einwirken, das dauert alles seine Zeit und wartet mal ab und es wird schon gut und so, ja, und äh Ergebnis nüscht.
Ja und vor allem der der größte der größte Schreihals für die äh Vorratszeitenspeicherung ist ja der Zirkel. Der ist ja SPD.
Oder unterstelle ich den da jetzt fast Schlechteres.
Nicht.
Ja, der ist der entstand aus der entstand der SPD Ursuppe.
Mhm. So. Tja.
Ja ja. BKA Präsident hier circa Mitglied der SPD.
So so, na dann, ist ja alles klar.
Hm? So.
Was ist das nächste große Thema, wenn wir jetzt schon Netznetralität und Vorzeitenspeicherung behandelt haben? Netzsperren sind ein schönes Thema für die netzpolitische äh Gesellschaft,
Und da gab's jetzt äh einen diesen Streitfall. Ich glaube, der Thomas hat uns da schon vor einiger Zeit mal von erzählt, als er bei uns zu Gast war,
da ging es um einen österreichischen ähm Streitfall zu netzsperren gegen Urheberrechtsverletzungen,
Und äh da ging es darum, dass die Konstantin Film und die Filmproduktionsgesellschaft Wega dem Internet Provider UPC Telekabel,
ähm vorschreiben wollten, er möge doch bitte die Seite Kino Punkt TO sperren. Das war diese Streaming Seite für Filme
ähm die irgendwie viel mit Werbung zugeballert wurde und die da relativ offensichtlich Bandenmäßig irgendwie Urheberrechtsverletzungen ausgenutzt haben, um sich äh durch Werbeeinnahmen zu finanzieren,
und der offene Art Drücker Kolonne hatten, was die Beschaffung dieser Videos anging. Ähm,
deren Seite sollte gesperrt werden. Und äh Konstantin und und Weger bekamen in in Österreich, in äh zwei Instanzen recht und der oberste Gerichtshof schobst dann an den EuGH.
Und dessen Generalanwalt Pedro Cruise Villa,
hat jetzt einen Schlussantrag zu dem Thema vorgelegt. Und üblicherweise folgt der Gerichtshof,
in seiner Entscheidung, den Ausführungen des Generalanwalts. Üblicherweise, ja? Und der gute Generalanwalt Pedro sagt also, ja, ein Vermittler,
In dem Fall der Internetprovider, dessen Dienste von einem Dritten, in dem Fall Kino TO, zur Verletzung des Urheberrechts genutzt werden.
Mhm, das sei er.
Von dem Kampf verhandelt verlangt werden, dass er das verhindert, ja? Dabei sei nicht erforderlich, dass der Zugangsanbieter mit dem eigentlichen Urheberrechtsverletzter eine direkte vertragliche Beziehung eingehe.
Das heißt, grundsätzlich sind solche Sperren eine Möglichkeit, das Urheberrecht durchzusetzen. Ist seiner Ansicht.
Ähm und dann sagt er, ja,
Ähm da war's dann so ein bisschen komisch. Dann ging's darum, ja, die können ja umgehbar sein, also sagen wir mal eine DNS-Sperre, ne. Man sagt,
Man sagt, der der DNS-Provider sagt nicht mehr hinter welcher IP-Adresse, Kino Punkt T O liegt. Aber jemand, der die IP-Adresse kennt, kann sich trotzdem noch dorthin verbinden,
Und dann sagt er, ey, ja, äh die können solche Sperren können's zwar umgeber sein, aber die Möglichkeit der Umgehung steht der eigentlichen Sperrverfügung
nicht im Wege, andererseits können ja dann auch die äh die Zugangsanbieter äh zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden oder haften, wenn sie die um diese Sperre nicht nicht lücken
losmachen. Also schwierige Einschätzung. Er hat sich da ein bisschen wenig zu dem eigentlichen zu dem eigentlichen,
Knackpunkt geäußert, aber er sagt zur Durchsetzung des Urheberrechts ähm ist das eine grundsätzlich eine akzeptable Maßnahme. So und sollte der EuGH dem jetzt folgen,
Dann haben wir demnächst Netzsperren äh zum bei Urheberrechtsverletzung, ja. Dann können wir demnächst auch nicht mehr auf Pirate Baid zugreifen, weil das wird natürlich dann als erstes gesperrt.
Und dann werden die VPN-Dienste gesperrt, die äh unzensiertes Internet anbieten und dann ist hier relativ schnell der Zappenduster. Zappenduster kennst du aber, ne?
Die NSA von der NSA gab's natürlich auch wieder, ihm wieder spannende Leaks in dieser Woche. Es ging dann um die Abteilung,
Taylor Access Operations und ähm,
diese Abteilung, das war jetzt so die, die sich auch damals um äh Belger kommen gekümmert hat, ja, also die diesen schönen Carier äh infiziert haben, damit ähm die USA da irgendwie Zugriff hatten.
Auf allen möglichen, auf alle möglichen Kommunikation.
Und jetzt sind sie auch dabei, äh das sozusagen über,
Also jetzt, jetzt, jetzt sind neue Dokumente rausgekommen, die quasi dieses generelle Taylor-Exzess gebaren, noch weiter in die Perspektive äh rückt.
Genau, denn offensichtlich haben sie das nicht nur bei Belgercom gemacht, sondern bei ähm,
ein paar mehr Computernetzwerken, fünfzigtausend.
Ach so.
Fünfzigtausend Computer,
Netzwerke haben sie mit Schadsoftware infiltriert, um an nicht öffentliche Informationen zu gelangen. Wo genau steht da nicht drin? Die Auflistung wäre ja auch ein bisschen lang geworden,
aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass es sich dabei umso kommunikationsrelevante Systeme wie die von eben Carryan oder Telekom-Anbietern handelt, also Belgercom scheint ja die eine gute Blaupause für die anderen fünfzigtausend zu sein.
Wer da wohl in Europa ähnliche Systeme hat. Also man kann sozusagen auch davon ausgehen, dass sie äh,
Also man kann zumindest davon ausgehen, dass sie alle größeren Provider auch direkt im Visier haben. Das war jetzt nicht Belger kommen wegen Brüssel und EU, besonders interessant, sondern es ist einfach eine generelle Strategie. Und es kann genauso gut könnte genauso gut sein, dass sie auch,
Telekom angreifen, Vodafone angreifen, O2 angreifen,
Was auch immer oder eben auch so was wie Kolt oder Level drei oder so, so werden die sich nicht sowieso schon beugen. Also,
mal so ein paar Namen zu nennen, wo das zutreffen könnte, ne.
Ich meine, verteil doch überhaupt mal. Verteil doch mal fünfzigtausend Netzwerke auf die Länder der Erde.
Ja, ich überlege auch gerade so, wie viele wie viele große Unternehmen gibt es eigentlich in Deutschland?
So im Sinne von wirklich relevant. Und wenn jetzt ein Computernetzwerk auch so was wie das Computernetzwerk von der Zentrale von Daimler Benz ist und dann haben die vielleicht noch so zehn Zentralen. Da bleibt einfach auch noch eine ganze Menge übrig.
Äh an Computernetzen, die man infiltrieren kann? Also ich denke mal, wenn du wenn du wenn du wirklich fünfzigtausend infiltriert hast, ja und ich weiß gar nicht, also die Anzahl der Länder der Erde ist, glaube ich, irgendwo hundertsechzig oder so was.
Nee, sind schon über zweihundert. Oder Andy, warte mal, du meinst jetzt äh ne, Entschuldigung, ich war jetzt gerade bei Sprachen.
Sprachen gibt's mehr, aber ich meine, das war irgendwie so eine äh ich finde das Wikipedia sind die leider nicht ähm nummeriert. Ich meine, das ist so grob.
Hundertdreiundneunzig.
Hundertdreiundneunzig so. Das heißt, ähm.
Jetzt kommt aber die Milchmilch Mädchenrechnung.
Na wieso? Also ähm,
über zweihundertfünfzig pro Land wären das.
Wenn man jetzt so, und das sind natürlich in anderen Ländern mehr, ja? Aber das heißt, wenn du da jetzt wirklich nur irgendwie die, wenn du da die DAX,
DAX hundert Unternehmen Deutschlands nehmen würdest und annimmst, okay die sind schon mal, dann hättest du nur wenn der Schnitt gewahrt ist und Deutschland kein übermäßiges Ziel ist, sondern nur seinen Anteil bekommt.
Noch hundertfünfzig frei. Hundertfünfzig.
Sind noch hundertfünfzig frei, ja? Also unter der unter der Annahme, dass jedes DAX-Unternehmen nur ein Netzwerk hat, was ja nicht stimmt, weil sie haben ganz viele, aber so die Hausnummer ist auf jeden Fall äh.
Und es heißt ja auch haben infiltriert nicht wollen infiltriert haben. Also die sind überall.
Völliger Irrsinn, völliger Irrsinn. Man kann von einer entfesselten Überwachung sprechen. Ja, so sieht das nämlich aus.
Eijeijei.
Gucken sie, wer irgendwie bei bei Zielpersonen gucken sie, was die sich denn für Pornos anschauen, um die eventuell irgendwie zu diskreditieren. Ja, kompromat sammeln, warum auch nicht.
Ja, Kompromat sammeln. Mhm. Ja. Könnte mal helfen.
Und ähm dann tauchte auch noch auf sehr, sehr äh elegant von den Jungs äh der Vier-Jahres-Plan von zweitausendzwölf. So ein so richtig schön formuliert mit,
Vision, Mission und werden,
in denen sich das die NSA fast schon so als eine Art Dienstleister äh zu verstehen scheint. Ähm,
Und dieser dieser vier Jahresplan wurde, wurde sehr ausführlich äh auch diskutiert in den in den
Kolumnen und und und Kommentaren, deswegen will ich da jetzt gar nicht so lange drauf eingehen. Letztendlich steht da natürlich nur drin, äh höher, besser, weiter, ne? Sascha Lober hat dann ein bisschen auch viel darüber geschrieben, dass wie sie sich da,
offensichtlich echt so als Konzern oder als als Unternehmen wahrnehmen. Das ist eine interessante Perspektive da auch,
Ich habe einfach mal nur beim Überfliegen einen Satz rausgenommen. Äh der lautet,
League Policys.
Die Politiker müssen sich genauso äh schnell beugen, wie sich die Technik weiterentwickelt.
Ja, sie müssen so dynamisch und anpassend sein, anpassungsfähig sein, wie die Technik, die wir angreifen. Das heißt, ähm mit anderen Worten, Gesetze müssen sich unseren Bedürfnissen unterordnen.
Ja und Politiker müssen sich vor allem ihren Bedürfnissen unterordnen. Ja, das ist.
Ist unglaublich.
Ist es einfach ein bisschen.
Also dieser dieser vierjahres Pan lässt da tief blicken. Es ist, glaube ich, kaum noch also weniger eine eine netzpolitische als auch eine als auch wirklich eine eine kulturelle Frage,
wie überhaupt sowas zustande kommen kann. Es ist eine sehr interessante Einblick, wie so ein Laden halt von innen denkt, ja. Und dass sie da nämlich schon längst natürlich,
über alles hinaus sind, da die stehen da auch nicht mehr auf äh äh morgens gehen zur Arbeit und sagen, ach spannend, jetzt wieder Kampf gegen den Terror,
Nein, Bullshit. Bullshit, die interne Kultur ist da eine ganz andere und das war ja auch schon immer klar. Ja, aber das das dokumentiert dieses ähm,
dieser dieser vier Jahres Plan sehr schön. Kann man mal reinschauen.
Teint. Nächstes Thema.
Nochmal, das habe ich nur ganz kurz nochmal mit reingenommen. Ich wollte das nur, das war eine kleine Meldung, die ich eigentlich nur mal mit aufnehmen wollte,
Und zwar hatte äh Clemens ja schon in der, in der vorletzten Folge von dem
Gateway-Protokoll gesprochen. Also das, wo sich mit dem sich die verschiedenen autonomen Systeme untereinander ähm,
äh mitteilen, wer wen wie gut erreichen kann. Es funktioniert ungefähr so.
Also zwei Netzs, Subnetze, Internetz, zwei autonome Systeme sind irgendwie miteinander verbunden und die glauben sich gegenseitig,
was wie gut ihre Routen sind,
Also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mit mit ähm mit fünf Ländern mit fünf verschiedenen autonomen Systemen verbunden bin
dann kann jedes davon mir sagen, ey, pass mal auf, äh dieser IP-Adressbereich hier, ne? Der ist genau bei mir, das ist nur ein Hops von mir
Super. Da kommst du über mich sehr schnell hin. Ja, oder der sagt, ja so. Und dann sagt ein anderer, von mir aus sind das so fünf Hops, kann ich dir anbieten.
Und ähm man das man entscheidet sich dann so für den kürzesten Weg so, so beißt sich das einfach ähm,
Also so so nivelliert sich dieses Routing relativ automatisch, ja? Dass man einfach so man muss da nicht mehr statisch irgendwie sagen,
Zu Google gehe ich über dieses Netz, weil das die Netze teil mir dynamisch mit, wie gut sie gerade was anderes erreichen. Da gab's schon ähm vor Jahren so einen Fall als einmal für eine, für einen gewissen Zeitraum,
China glaube ich ungefähr gesagt hat über dieses Protokoll an alle seine Interconnects übrigens alles wo ihr hinwollt,
steht bei mir.
Und dann ging einfach mal so der Welt-Traffic für aller Traffic der Welt für acht Minuten durch China. Und äh wenn du sowas ähm,
Sowas passiert manchmal, durch eine Fehlkonfiguration und dann hast du natürlich so ein so ein sofort dieses dieser Teil des Netzes ist natürlich dann platt. Weil da alles reingeht und äh sich dann da ist einfach dann Schicht im.
China war das.
Ich meine das war China gewesen. Ja vor, das sind ein paar Jahre her, drei, vier Jahre her.
Mal irgendwas betürkei oder Pakistan.
Da komme ich gleich zu, genau, das ist die nächste Geschichte, so und ähm das Interessante ist also, weil man eben davon ausgeht, dass eine Route zu Announcen,
die man nicht wirklich erfüllen kann,
Ähm weder im Interesse des Anbieters ist noch im Interesse der Anderen, gibt's in diesem Protokoll erstmal keine kein Sicherheitsmechanismus, der das überprüft. Das heißt, wenn ich das announce, kriege ich das auch,
Und das hat ähm Pakistan mal vor ungefähr zwei Jahren, haben die gesagt, ach ähm,
Wir wollen äh YouTube sperren. Wir announcen jetzt hier einfach an einer Stelle YouTube. Ja, also so,
bei uns geht's echt sehr, sehr schnell und sehr gut zu YouTube. Und dann war YouTube in Pakistan äh gesperrt.
Beziehungsweise wurde dann so wie der Clemens das auch vor zwei Wochen erzählt hatte, das heißt alle YouTube requests gingen dorthin,
obwohl YouTube erreichbar war und der quasi eine bessere Route dahin angeboten hat als jeder andere, dann aber die IP-Pakete einfach versenkt hat,
Was er aber nicht bedacht hatte war, dass alle, die jetzt da dranhängen und sehen, ey Pakistan,
null Hobs bis Google oder so, ne? Äh bis YouTube, ähm dann ist es durch Micha, dann sage ich das jetzt mal meinen Freunden, dass wenn sie zu YouTube wollen, sie nur bei mir lang müssen. Und so propagierte sich diese Information,
Das Park, das in Pakistan auf einmal YouTube ist, durch das gesamte Internet und führte dazu, dass irgendwann äh in weiten Teilen der Welt ähm YouTube dann nicht erreichbar war, weil sich die ganzen autonomen Systeme diese Route.
Alle wollten an diesen geilen super schnellen YouTube-Server in Pakistan. Genau. Mhm.
So, also so vereinfacht gesprochen, ne, technische Details jetzt äh verschönt.
Und das das sind so die die bekannten die bekannteren, interessanten Fälle an Monipulationen mit dem Boarder Gateway-Protokoll. Insgesamt interessiert sich da aber wohl kaum jemand drüber. Kaum jemand dafür, solange alles funktioniert.
Ja, vor allem solange das auch so im Wesentlichen von so,
gestandenen Admins mit äh Berufsethos äh durchgeführt wird. Ja, so Amics und äh solche Orte, äh,
wo es um das eigentliche Ziel geht, dass das Internet zu optimieren. Aber das Problem hier ist versucht vermutlich, kannst du das ja gleich nochmal ausfüllen,
Problem, was wir eigentlich durch die Bank in der gesamten technischen Entwicklung der Kommunikationstechnik,
in den letzten dreißig vierzig Jahren sehen, nehme ich das einfach ein,
Also viele Aspekte werden bedacht. Stabilität, Zuverlässigkeit, Flexibilität, Preis, Dauer, alles, ja? Aber Misstrauen,
ist in diesen technischen Protokollen selten drin, ja. Telefon, ja, klar, der User äh muss sich authentifizieren, das Netz muss sich nicht authentifizieren. Wunderbare Abhör äh Möglichkeit.
WLANs, ja, du buchst dich in ein WLAN ein, was Telekom heißt und denkst irgendwie, ja, hier, das ist ja bestimmt ein Telekom-Hotspot und dann schicke ich da mal meinen Look hin, und so. Ja, äh
kann halt irgendwas sein und so weiter, also immer wieder diesesselbe Problem, vor allem, dass ich Netze eben nicht richtig authentifizieren, darüber dann aber doch sehr vertrauensvolle Kommunikation stattfindet.
Hier ist es halt eben auch dieser Austausch über die Internet-Infrastruktur
ja? Klar, da weiß man natürlich schon, mit wem man redet, aber das, was da eben ausgehandelt wird so,
Sind ja erstmal alles nur Behauptungen, die äh auch gehalten werden müssen.
Dieser WLAN also beide äh dieser WLAN-Angriff funktioniert, glaube ich nun nur bei WEP-Netzwerken, aber äh bei WPA sollte das nicht mehr funktionieren.
Weil ich
vorsichtig jetzt, ich glaube, weil bei WPA das ein Preset-Key ist, den ihr also beide Instanzen als gewusst voraussetzen und nutzen und deshalb niemals wirklich verraten.
Also die WLAN-Anmeldung bei WPA ist nicht, dass du sagst, hallo, hier ist mein Kennwort folgendes, ich möchte rein, sondern dass du schon verschlüsselt mit diesem Schlüssel sagst, hallo, ich möchte.
Rede einfach von offenen Netzen, die einfach irgendwie heißen.
Achso, offenes Netz, ja ja.
So ein Telekom-Hotspot, der da brauchst du ja keinen Passwort, um da reinzukommen, sondern Passwörter gibst du dann danach äh ein, ja klar, du klappst halt deinen Rechner irgendwo auf. Oh, hier ist ja ein WLAN.
Aber der der Angriff, der, glaube ich, bei WEP noch möglich war, auch jetzt vorsichtig ist, dass ich einfach ein WLAN aufsetze, was genauso heißt, wie deins zu Hause,
Aber woanders du vorbeiläufst dein iPhone sich da einwählt und ich dann deinen Schlüssel habe,
Ähm ich bin mir aber bei bei beiden jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher, müsste ich nochmal mir genau anschauen, deswegen vorsichtig, gefährliches Halbwissen, aber die Idee ist ähm.
Ja, aber grundsätzlich, also ich sage ja nur, Misstrauen ist irgendwie nicht ausgeprägt in den ganzen Protokollen. Und das ist natürlich auch besonders im Internet so, weil dieses Internet ist,
Einfach geprägt,
Von Vertrauen und ja und ja das waren alles irgendwie so Wissenschaftler und die meinten das ja nur gut mit sich und allen anderen. Und jetzt fällt einem das halt auf die Füße und nur kurz oder lang müssen
vermutlich alle nennenswerten Protokolle,
Teilweise findet diese Diskussion ja auch schon statt, also so bei der AETF und so, da hört man immer mehr so Leute äh ja,
die Themenlage für die nächsten Treffen
ändert sich, wir müssen wirklich darüber nachdenken, wie wir unsere kritischen Infrastrukturen hinbekommen. Wir müssen irgendwie E-Mail fixen, wir müssen äh auch solche Sachen äh äh fixen und Prinzip, glaube ich, gibt's jetzt,
Bei nahezu jedem wichtigen Internetprotokoll, was für die Infrastruktur zuständig ist oder für die Infrastruktur einen großen Wert darstellt,
muss diese äh Überlegung ganz wieder neu angestellt werden.
Also halten wir fest ähm beim Gateway-Protokoll ist erstmal
nicht mit eingebaut, dass man das, was einem der andere sagt, auch wirklich überprüft
Das ist äh hier der der entscheidende Punkt, weil man eben beim beim Design vor vielen Jahren davon ausgegangen ist, dass es für niemanden wirklich von Interesse ist, ähm Routen äh zu, die man, die man nicht hat oder für die man nicht wirklich die beste.
Option ist. Und ähm.
Wie gesagt, zwei Beispiele für für Missbrauch äh des Protokolls habe ich da jetzt mal äh genannt.
Und jetzt ist eine eine Firma hingegangen und hat gesagt, ach wir wir schauen einfach mal äh die ganze Zeit ähm,
Wie siehst du dieses Protokoll verhält? Da da ändern sich ja auch andauernd Sachen, ne? Also da,
Dass es so schnell geht, äh oder der Tatsache, dass es so schnell geht, verdanken wir auch eben die Stabilität des Netzes, ja, dass es immer so schön funktioniert. Und ähm,
Die sind also hingegangen und haben über sechzig Tage mal diese Änderungen der der äh angeschaut,
und haben ähm eine ganze Menge ähm Umleitungen gefunden, die sie so als gezielte Entführung einstufen. Und zum Beispiel gab es da ein ähm.
Einen äh Angriff irgendwie aus aus Island, ja, der hat dann irgendwie, wo der gesamte ähm Traffic äh von zwischen zwei Internetprovidern in Denver Colorado, einmal durch Island geroutet. Ähm,
und äh Weißrussland hat äh offensichtlich dann so jeden Tag einen anderen Teil des Internets irgendwie einmal bei sich durchgeleitet und so. Das heißt, da findet wohl relativ ähm,
relativ gezielter Missbrauch mit dem, mit dem Protokoll statt, um sich jeweils mal so einen Teil ähm geben zu lassen und da mal einfach reinzuschauen.
Das ist einfach wirklich die die Definition von Selbstbedienung, Mentalität.
Ja, alles, was du brauchst, sind natürlich starke äh Router, die das auch wegpacken, ja?
Solange da nur weiß ich nicht, ein paar Millisekunden irgendwie sich ändern für die Nutzer oder gar nichts von der Geschwindigkeit her, äh kannst du das natürlich gut machen, ne?
Und ähm jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, okay, immer wenn so ein Announcement kommt,
muss das ein Admin prüfen und und freischalten. Aber wie gesagt, das passiert die ganze Zeit und sehr viel und sehr schnell,
und ähm in der Regel funktioniert's ja auch gut und keiner merkt, dass ein Problem ist, ja? Und es wäre ja auch kein Problem, wenn wir einfach mal
in Zukunft keine unverschlüsselten Protokolle mehr hätten, ja? Das wird ja schon also das wird ja schon einen großen Teil
des Problemes äh eindämmen. Dann hätten wir immer noch das Problem, dass irgendwie äh andere Länderdaten sammeln können. Ähm aber,
das Hauptproblem im Moment ist irgendwie war das YouTube, die haben äh nicht YouTube Yaru, die haben jetzt irgendwie vor Kurzem,
HTTPS jetzt mal eingeschaltet für Ihr Mail, ja? Für Ihr Webmail.
Jetzt für Kunden meinst du?
Vor kurzem, ja?
Ja, das ist ja auch bei Facebook alles noch nicht so lange her und das ist auch weiß auch gar nicht, ob das schon alles so so durchgehend äh äh deployd ist. Das ist das ist so ein Prozess, ja, auch äh am Anfang bei der Wikipedia, ja?
War das auch äh jahrelang so, dass irgendwie alle Logins äh unverschüsselt waren. Hat ja auch immer so. Leute,
Ja eigentlich so, ja? Wollt ihr das? Wollt ihr das eure ganze Infrastruktur übernommen würden, ne? Weil damals hat man das, glaube ich, noch nicht so als was großes, wichtiges angesehen. Das ist natürlich jetzt komplett anders. Eigentlich müsste der komplette IP-Traffic verschlüsselt sein.
Ja ja, also es sollte einfach keine, ja, vielleicht auch schon auf dem Lehrjahr. Also vielleicht jetzt nicht im im Detail, nee, aber das.
Naja, aber das ist halt genau das Ding. Ich meine, in dem Moment, wo man halt so BGP äh äh spricht, das ist quasi dann nur so ein Tunneling ist
ja? Können ja können ja gerne Weißrussland dann den kompletten Traffic bei sich durchtunneln, den komplett verschlüsselten so viel.
Für sie nicht mehr interessant.
Äh und dann wird das eben auch so nicht mehr stattfinden. Ja, da muss noch so einiges geschehen.
Da muss noch ähm da muss noch eine Menge geschehen und wie gesagt, dass ich, ich denke, dass es inzwischen die Lehre, die ich ja auch schon öfter hier mal wiederholt habe, so
eine unverschlüsselte Verbindung, sollte man einfach heute nicht mehr eingehen, egal, was man tut, ja. Also ähm wie gesagt, es geht dabei nicht nur um das Risiko des Abhörens, also ich meine, könnte sich jetzt so sagen, ja, ich meine
Wenn ich auf eine öffentliche Seite wie Spiegel Online gehe, dann ähm ist es vernachlässigbar
welche Artikel ich da lese, denn auf dieser Seite gibt es irgendwie nichts, was was nicht
öffentlich ist, außer vielleicht der Kommentare, die ich dahin poste und der Passwörter, die ich nutze, um mich da zu identifizieren. Aber ein weiteres Risiko von unverschlüsselten Verbindungen ist eben auch, dass sie manipuliert werden können und da dann eben, was weiß ich, einen in dem HTML noch ein kleines äh Flash-Explod eingebunden wird,
was äh nebenbei noch kurz dein Rechner infiziert, alles äh.
Falsche Information. Also einfach der Inhalt ist überhaupt modifiziert wird.
Also unverschlüsselte Verbindungen sind bäh und äh diese Angriffe zeigen ähm warum?
Und natürlich äh wird dann immer, wenn wenn das dann auffliegt, dann sagt man, ja, tut uns leid. Der Praktikant, der äh musste das jetzt auch mal lernen mit dem BGP und da hat er echt. Also, da haben wir echt lange gebraucht, bis wir gemerkt haben, dass der ähm,
was er da für einen Fehler macht. Bei China übrigens als der Vorfall von China war vor ein paar Jahren ähm da hat man das eher interpretiert also da war eigentlich die Welt erstaunt, dass China das gepackt hat,
diesen ganzen Traffic ähm zu ruten. Da hat man das eher als so eine Art ähm,
Macht Demonstrationen oder Last-Tests gesehen, dass äh China also sagte so hier, weißt du, so so wie so ein Atomwaffentest, den man ja auch als als Großmacht äh anscheinend irgendwie alle.
Ein guter äh Test, das könnte sich die große Koalition dann auch gleich mal äh sozusagen als Benchmark in ihre Netzausbaupläne äh reinmachen, wenn wir acht Minuten lang den kompletten Internet-Traffic überleben, dann äh.
Ich weiß nicht, ob's bei China der Gesamte war, bei Gruppen von weiten Teilen, ne.
Kleine Brötchen backen, ne?
Router mal testen, muss ja auch mal warm werden, der Nachbrenner, der hier steht.
Ja, genau.
Also so viel noch mal zu den zu den Ruten, ne. Wie gesagt, man könnte das um äh man könnte das äh festschreiben und sagen, okay, wir lassen bestimmte Routen nicht mehr vom BGP ändern,
oder wir setzen da jemanden hin, der das alles, der immer auf okay klickt den ganzen Tag, das wird nichts ändern. Hätte geringes äh Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sich da was ändern würde.
Fand ich nur mal ganz interessant.
Wir müssen es ja alle keine Sorgen machen über Überwachung, weil die UNO jetzt äh in demnächst mit einem,
umfangreichen und zielgerichteten der Weltöffentlichkeit gegenübertreten wird,
ihr riecht ja alle nach Ludo und stinkt und äh kommt mal klar. Deutschland ist schuld.
Ja, Deutschland hat das, hat es angeleiert. Da hat Deutschland mal richtig, richtig ähm.
Richtig was bewegt.
Richtig was gerissen? Ja.
Ja, vielleicht hat sogar Herr Wesserwelle mitgemacht.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ich glaube, dass sie noch nicht äh jetzt verabschiedet wurde, sondern erst nächsten Dienstag. Vielleicht wurde sie auch schon ähm.
Die wurde, glaube ich, noch nicht äh angenommen, aber sie ist auf jeden Fall schon ordentlich entschärft worden. Also diese Initiative von Deutschland und Brasilien,
die halt darauf zielte, äh diese ganzen Überwachungen äh zu äh ächten. Die ist jetzt,
soweit abgemildert worden, dass da halt auf jeden Fall auch keine Länder genannt werden, die das irgendwie tun würden und ähm.
Es ist eine eine Initiativ eine eine Resolution gegen internationale Abhör- und Späh Aktion,
Von der UNO, von der UNO-Vollversammlung, die, anders als der UNO-Sicherheitsrat überhaupt gar keinen Druckmittel hat, diese ähm Sanktionen,
erzwingen. Äh diese diese Resolution zu erzwingen. Sie kann nur ächten. Also es ist quasi ein ein Blatt Papier,
ohne jegliche Sanktionsmöglichkeit, sondern sagt einfach nur das finden wir nicht gut, wenn das gemacht wird, das verstößt gegen diese Resolution und dann kann man die Sanktion ist, man kann dann sagen, dass es gegen diese Resolution verstößt.
So wenn man seine kleinen Kinder irgendwie vorm Spiel mit dem Feuer abhalten wollen mit also wenn wenn du das jetzt nicht sofort aufhörst, dann finde ich das nicht gut.
Genau, dann finden wir mal das nicht gut,
und ähm in der Resolution wird weder die USA noch die NSA namentlich genannt. Das ist, ich meine,
Ja und sie hat drei Seiten, knapp drei Seiten äh und in denen festgestellt wird, Menschenrechte gelten online ebenso wie offline,
und unrechtmäßige oder willkürliche Überwachungsmaßnahmen ähm können äh verletzt werden,
Ach so können, können diese Menschenrechte verletzen, ja? Innerstaatlich und extraterritorial. Ähm,
und alle Staaten werden doch freundlich gebeten, ihre Rechtslage dementsprechend zu überprüfen. Das werden sie bestimmt tun. Ich merke schon, wie sie äh
wie sie emsig äh sich an die Arbeit machen. Da haben Deutschland mal richtig ihre Muskeln gezeigt.
Genau, da fällt mir wenigstens großartige Titanic-Booster aus den achtziger Jahren ein mit dem Titel unglaublich, Bonn rettet den Wald,
So ein Foto von dem Wald, an dem so ein gelbes Schild ist, genau, Waldsterben verboten, die Bundesregierung. Ja, so ist es jetzt so ein bisschen auch irgendwie so Bonn. Äh Berlin rettet die Freiheit, ne? Überwachung verboten. Ja, danke.
Danke, vielen Dank. Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas spannendes? Ja, denke schon. Wirklich?
Ja, denke schon. Ja, also ich würde, das ist jetzt eher sonisten,
Pflicht, der ich da nachkommen möchte, sei es in dieser Woche, äh wird da viel drüber gesprochen über ähm,
Forschungsprogramme deutscher Universitäten, die äh relativ direkt gefördert werden vom amerikanischen Militär oder seinen äh,
Seinen Zulieferern. Und das sind teilweise deutsche Unis, die diese Friedensklausel haben und sagen, wir machen nur äh friedliche Forschung,
und ähm da wird sich dann auch gerne damit rausgeredet, ja äh wir machen ja hier nur wissenschaftliche Grundlagenforschungen,
und äh die ist ja dann der für die Allgemeinheit oder so, ne. Also das äh,
zeigt mal noch, was hier also es ist gerade Thema. Ich habe mich da jetzt nicht großartig mit auseinandergesetzt. Ähm ich lese das mit Interesse und bin da auch nicht ähm.
Es ist jetzt nicht ein genoin-netzpolitisches Thema,
Ich wollt's doch mal erwähnen, weil das halt in diesem ganzen Überwachungs- und Militarisierungskomplex äh ja dann doch auch eine Rolle spielt, ja? Und jetzt auch gerade heute wieder getitelt wird über die,
Drohnen, äh die dann da offensichtlich aus der deutschen Airforce-Basis Ramstein äh gesteuert werden. Da haben wir also nochmal eine eine ganz andere Dimension,
die ich glaube hier nicht vertieft werden kann leider aber auch nicht unerwähnt bleiben sollte.
Ja, also das da muss ich, ich meine, äh was mir bei den Berichten jetzt nicht ganz klar geworden ist, ist es wirklich explizit, sind es wirklich explizit von der NSA vergebene äh Forschungsaufträge,
Bitte? Also from the guys, whoop, broad use, Internet sozusagen.
So ungefähr.
Also ich mein Internet ist ja auch mal vom äh Militär gestartet worden. Da kann man jetzt immer schön hin und her argumentieren. Ja, das ist äh man muss sich schon immer fragen, wenn jemand Geld gibt, warum tut er das?
Und ich glaube jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass das so das primäre Ziel des amerikanischen Verteidigungsministeriums ist, die Forschungslandschaft in Deutschland zu stärken.
Ich hatte.
Also nicht primär, ja? Sekundär würde ich das noch nicht mal ausschließen, ja. Aber da muss man äh sich auf jeden Fall Gedanken zu machen.
Gut. Letzte Runde ist Pflicht für heute. Aufm Kongress hinweisen.
S. Ja, auf den Kongress hinweisen. Ich denke, das kann man jetzt mal machen.
Ja, haben wir ja gestern in der auch schon sehr ausführlich getan.
Da war ich nicht dabei.
Ausführlich müssen wir das aber auch nicht machen, weil dann nochmal die ganze Sendung dranhängen.
Also, der äh Kongress beginnt in etwas.
Chaos Communication Kongress des Chaos Computer.
Der Chaos Communication Kongress des Clubs der Discoscomputerclubs ähm.
Richtig schön verpeilt, sagen willst, hast du Computer-Chaos-Club. Das ist so etwas, was ich.
Chaoten aus dem Computerclub.
Sind die Chaoten aus dem Computerclub, genau.
Die Chaoten versammeln sich in Hamburg am siebenundzwanzigsten bis zum dreißigsten Dezember äh diesen Jahres äh im Kongresszentrum,
Ähm das wird,
also nicht nur, weil es der Dreißigste ist, sicherlich ein ein sehr fulminanter Kongress. Möchte da äh oder ich werde da in der, denke ich mal, in den in den kommenden Sendungen auch nochmal auf das äh Programm im Bereich im politischen Bereich ähm,
Hinweisen an dessen Ausfall ich äh beteiligt war
haben wir, glaube ich, sehr äh eine sehr gute, ein sehr ein überragendes Angebot auf jeden Fall gehabt an an Vorträgen, von denen wir dann leider gezwungen waren, nur eine kleine Auswahl äh.
Zu erhöhen, ja?
Was ist das ja wohl eine Frechheit. Also äh.
Euch sicherlich ordentlich bemüht haben. Du kannst vielleicht auch kurz was dazu sagen. Also äh den dreißig C drei unterscheidet sich ja auf vielen Ebenen äh vom letzten.
Finde ich, ja, also da tut sich so einiges, räumliche Ausdehnungen et cetera, pipapo, also war zwar letztes Jahr schon ein großer Sprung, aber dieses Jahr ist ja äh kommt ja nochmal was dazu, aber ist auch,
Inhaltlich organisatorisch neu aufgestellt gewesen, als das jetzt erstmalig es nicht ein Content Team gab, was das gesamte Programm beschlossen hat, was immer zu viel Reibereien äh führte bei so nicht artverwandten Themenbereichen,
Und dieses Mal wurde, ich weiß gar nicht, in wie viele Teile aufgespalten, fünf.
Es, es, also das Programm wurde in in fünf Tracks unterteilt vorher. Es wurden einfach fünf Tracks. Man konnte seine Einreichung einem der fünf Tracks zuordnen. Das waren einmal Safety und Security. Dann,
EX Politics and Society. Ähm Science-in Engineering, Art and Beauty.
Und Crafting and Making. Ja? Und ähm die dann wurde,
schon einen kam, gab es weit über dreihundert Einreichungen, glaube ich, insgesamt, die sich etwas ungleichmäßig auf diese äh auf diese verschiedenen Bereiche verteilten.
Die Zahlen würden mich ja mal interessieren.
Security und ähm Politics hatten jeweils um die einhundertdreißig, genaue Zahlen habe ich jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber ist so die Hausnummer war um die hundert.
So die prozentuale Verteilung, also äh was.
Kann ich dir, kann ich dir gerne mal zeigen.
Mal was für die nächste Woche. Hm?
Genau, reden wir nächste Woche nochmal drüber. Also der in Richtung prozentualer Verteilung wollte ich da eh noch ein paar andere Auswertungen auch machen.
Und dann wurde quasi auch schon vorher grob festgelegt, wie viele Slots im Programm oder wie viele Stunden im Programm jedem einzelnen Thema ähm zugebilligt werden,
Und das waren äh dann auch so für Security und Politics jeweils so um die dreißig, wie gesagt, genauer Zahlen interessieren jetzt auch nicht. Ähm.
Damit eben, ne, wer jetzt gut aufgepasst hat, weiß, so wir mussten,
einfach per se eine ganze Menge äh Vorträge ablehnen. Und es war zumindest im Politikbereich und im in den anderen Bereichen habe ich das genauso gehört, so dass wir,
wirklich von der Qualität der Einreichung sehr ähm,
sehr begeistert waren und ähm große Schwierigkeiten hatten, eben Einreichungen, die wir sehr gerne mit dabei haben wollten, dann eben ablehnen zu müssen aus einfach Platzmangel, ne. Da sind also äh ich glaube, es war,
wir haben viele der Ablehnung wirklich mitgeschrieben mit der Begründung, ey wir fanden das super, aber wir haben keinen Platz im Programm. Ähm wir würden dich gerne dabei haben, aber.
Geht einfach nicht, weil der Kongress müsste einfach noch noch noch größer, noch länger na ja, ich meine das Fernziel lautet ja Dauerkongress.
Was, was wiederum dazu führt, dass ähm viele der abgelehnten, ja, wobei ich, wie gesagt, also es gibt, es gibt ein Unfrage, es gibt eine ganze Menge Einreichungen, die wurden einfach abgelehnt.
Die waren einfach nicht.
Okay, ja das gibt's immer. Es ist immer irgendwas dabei, was einfach überhaupt nicht in Frage kommt.
Oder ihr die entsprachen auch vielleicht nicht den den Qualitätsanspruch oder äh die waren behandelten Themen, die im
in diesem Jahr nicht äh besondere Bedeutsamkeit haben oder sonst was. Also es gibt Ablehnungen und es gibt einfach einen großen Anteil an Talks, die es einfach nicht ins Programm geschafft haben,
Und diese werden hoffentlich zu großen Teilen in deniz Sessions, also als Workshops, dann in den äh Workshop-Räumen.
Gehalten, so meine Hoffnung. Bin halt gerade mit vielen,
Referenten, die sind wir da auch am am rumverhandeln. Also langer Rede, kurzer Sinn, wir haben ein ein Programm dieses Jahr, was wirklich sich sehen lassen kann,
Gerade im Politikbereich, im Security-Bereich äh ähnlich. Die anderen Bereiche, da habe ich keine nennenswerte Expertise und vertraue da aber sehr auf die anderen Track-Teams,
ähm.
Auch andere Gäste dieses Programms wiederum äh schon eine Rolle
haben, also Gregor ist zum Beispiel da der äh bei Atem Beauty ganz äh in der ersten äh Reihe äh vertreten. Der Falk war auch mit äh dabei, der hier neulich bei der zu Gast war. Also.
Wenn du jetzt hier schon Namen nennst, äh ich weiß gar nicht, ob er ob das so öffentlich war, wer da alles drin ist, deswegen sage ich.
Nö, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht sonderlich geheim.
Nee, also genau, ähm es waren dann wirklich in jedem Track-Team ähm ja, Experten für ihr, für ihren Themenbereich und das hat, glaube ich, zu einer ähm zu einer,
Interessanteren Auswahl oder zu einer saubereren Auswahl geführt, weil von vorne herein nicht ein Security-Talk jetzt mit einem Politik-Talk,
konkurriert hat, weil wir eben von vorne herein wussten, so viele Slots gibt's für ähm diesen Track.
Also dieses Quotha war einfach festgelegt.
Quoten waren festgelegt, haben aber dann, auch das kann ich erzählen, dazu geführt, dass wir beim dritten Content Treffen dann gesagt haben.
Müssen wir über die Quoten reden, ja.
Wir brauchen noch einen Raum. Und äh deswegen gibt es dieses Jahr vier Räume. Was dann dazu geführt hat, dass wir eben statt,
der ursprünglichen einundzwanzig äh oder oder unter zwanzig Slots dann eben knapp unter dreißig haben im im Politikbereich. Alle, wie gesagt, handverlesen und von von besonders hoher Qualität.
Deswegen werbe ich sehr äh für den Besuch des Kongresses und dann habe ich.
Oder auch die Remoteverfolgung des Kongresses, muss man dazu sagen, da wird ja nun wirklich komplett gestreamt und ist jetzt nicht unbedingt zwingend nötig, vor Ort zu sein, um den Inhalt zu folgen. Ich würde sogar fast
manchmal sagen, um dem, wenn man jetzt wirklich am Vortragsprogramm an Interesse hat, dann ist man manchmal hinter so einem äh Stream-Endgerät äh äh,
sehr viel besser bedient, also wirklich so für für Junkies. Das steht dann aber sozusagen immer noch in der Konkurrenz mit dieser wirklich,
unglaublichen Präsenzerfahrungen, die man auf diesem Kongress äh machen kann, ne? Und natürlich auch der Möglichkeit, all diesen Leuten, die da geredet haben, vielleicht im Nachgang auch äh Frage zu stellen.
Genau, man hat äh hat die Möglichkeit dann wirklich diese diese Menschen eben auch zu sehen, ja und mit den mit denen zu sprechen und ähm,
Worauf ich nämlich eigentlich hinaushöre, warum ich das hier so so ausführlich erzähle ist, ähm dass ich so von mehreren Leuten immer wieder hört man das, dass Leute sich nicht dahin trauen,
Ähm du hast ganz, ganz das war doch in einem Podcast mit dir, wo dann auch der äh Kasper äh Leitmedium zum Beispiel erzählt hatte, dass er sich irgendwie anfangs nicht dahin getraut hat, nach Hamburg gefahren ist, äh vor der Tür. Er.
Er stand vor der Tür. Vor der Tür, ja, ja. Ja, ja, genau.
Oder ähm auch ganz interessant, dass der ähm.
Ja oder überhaupt, dass man denkt, man müsse einen Hacker sein oder sonst irgendwie irgendeinen Status äh oder irgendein gewisse technische äh Grundfähigkeit besitzen muss. Und ich finde, das ist einfach nicht.
'n Interesse haben. Es geht nicht darum die Fähigkeit zu haben, es geht darum 'ne Begeisterung zu haben. Ich denke das ist das was man mitbringen sollte, wenn man da keine Begeisterung für hat, dann ist es einfach auch nicht die richtige Veranstaltung.
Also wenn man sich schon fragt, ob man da vielleicht mal hin sollte, dann ist man eigentlich da schon am richtigen Ort.
Worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist, dass eben, wie gesagt, viele Menschen sich irgendwie da Sorgen drum machen oder nicht wissen, ob sie dahingehören oder zum Beispiel der Martin Fischer vom vom Staatsbürgerkunde Podcast, dann irgendwie äh sich schon zwei Monate im Voraus Gedanken machte, wie er denn sein
Computer absicherte, wenn er sich da den,
legitime Frage.
Ja, ja. Keine Frage, die man sich nicht auch sonst stellen sollte, aber.
War dann auch meine Antwort,
Frage dir jetzt zu stellen. Also ich meine, inzwischen ist es, glaube ich, so, dass das, dass es reine Internet eine größere Bedrohung darstellt, als das ähm äh Kongressnetz,
Was aber sicherlich äh,
nicht immer so waren, ja? Also natürlich sind da wird da auch äh Quatsch gemacht in dem Netz und ähm man sollte sich da irgendwie grob äh darauf vorbereiten. Deswegen gibt's auch diese Vicky-Seite, in der so grob mal drinsteht, wie man zumindest
die scheuen Tore an seinem Rechner zumacht,
Ähm aber, was es dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal gibt, ist das System der oder das Angebot der Chaos-Patinnen.
Und äh dass dieses Angebot wendet sich genau an an so Leute, die,
ähm,
vielleicht auch manchmal ist es auch so eine Sache von ich musste alleine hingehen. Ich habe jetzt keine, man hat keine Leute im Freundeskreis, die damit hingehen, ja?
Oder mein Freund geht dahin, ich möchte eigentlich mit dem die Zeit verbringen, andererseits will ich auch nicht als als seine als sein Partner oder seine Partner.
Anhang wahrgenommen.
Anhang rumhängen. Und deswegen gibt's so ein so ein Mentorenprogramm dieses Jahr,
Ähm was ich eben insbesondere an an Erstbesucher richtet, die einfach vielleicht so einen Einstieg zu dem Kongress suchen, die sie.
Einfach mal jemand haben wollen.
Der ihnen sagt so.
Ich nehme dich mal in die Hand, ich zeige dir mal, was Sache.
Zeig dir mal ein paar coole Sachen, ja?
Genau. Das ist cool, ist eine eine wirklich eine sehr coole Idee. Wo kommt die her?
Die,
Zurück ich glaube, die wurde letztes Jahr sich irgendwie im Feedback gewünscht. Also die Idee stand schon irgendwie im Vicky aus dem letzten,
Programm. Das so irgendwie war so auf der Liste man Malliste.
Und äh der Idee haben sich jetzt äh hauptsächlich zwei äh junge Damen angenommen, May und Fiona, die wir auch beide kennen. Und ähm die die ziehen das da jetzt hoch.
Cool. Das wirklich super,
Ich kenne das auch, also wenn man auf so Veranstaltungen kommt und man sieht das alles, ist irgendwie alles ganz interessant, aber da weiß man nicht so richtig, wie spricht man die jetzt an? Wer ist denn jetzt hier eigentlich wichtig? Keine Ahnung und dann scheut man natürlich schnell davor zurück und er geht sehr viel bei verloren, weil
Gewagte ansprechen und das Richtige, die richtige Person rauspicken, ähm das kann einfach eine Menge bringen, ja? Ich meine äh ich weiß nicht, wie viele Kongresse du jetzt schon äh
mitgemacht hast. Linus.
Ich sage da nichts zu. Ja, eine eine Anzahl.
Na, aber sagen wir mal so, du hast jetzt auch genug äh genug Erfahrung mit dem Kongress gesammelt, dass wenn du da jetzt so hinkommst, dass du sagen wir mal so für so die ähm,
wesentlichen Dauerbrenner äh des Kongresses, also so diese Gruppen, die immer da sind, da hast du auch schon in etwa ein Gespür dafür
Personen sind, die man da ansprechen wollen würde, um mal die richtige Information zu bekommen, wie denn jetzt irgendwas gemacht ist dieses Jahr. Ja, man weiß, wo man irgendwie beim Nock aufschlagen muss, man weiß, wie man bei den Telefonleuten da mal
die richtigen äh Infos rauskitzelt. So, das ist einfach so eine Erfahrungssache und wenn man die eben,
so weitergegeben bekommt und auch sagen wir mal sich dann diese Patinnen.
Ja, ich glaube.
Schnell da reinarbeiten und man weiß immer schon so, ah, da wird mal wieder jemand.
Es geht doch nicht darum.
Das ist super.
Genau, es geht eigentlich darum, diesen Einstieg zu finden und einfach, also ich ich glaube, dass dass ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass das irgendwie ein System wird, wo wo einfach die ganze Leute die ganze Zeit nur Leute in Fünfergruppen Händchen haltend da durchgeführt werden. Es geht einfach darum, so ihr kommt da an,
Da ist jemand für euch bei Fragen. Der zeigt euch ein paar coole Sachen,
Lasst euch in Ruhe und wenn ihr Fragen habt, ist äh ist äh für euch da, ja?
Reiseführer.
Ja, wobei ich ich mich so ein bisschen auch dagegen wehre, dass das jetzt Reiseführer sind, weil man ist, es soll natürlich schon noch ein Community Event sein und die, ich glaube, der der Anspruch ist jetzt nicht da, äh da den den so da jetzt irgendwie.
Auf der rechten Seite sehen sie eine intelligente Netzwerkinstallation.
Hier werden die Bits handverlesen. Nein, sowas, sowas natürlich nicht. Also es soll, es richtet sich an Leute, die natürlich auch schon äh äh genoines Interesse an dieser Community haben und nicht irgendwie an ähm.
Ne, es ist äh es ist wirklich super. Ich mag den Gedanken.
Dieses System gibt's und wer sich dazu berufen fühlt, da zum Beispiel auch mitzumachen als Pate oder als Patin. Ist natürlich herzlich aufgerufen, das zu tun und.
Wendet sich jetzt vor allem, sagen wir mal auch an die Leute, die schon einfach den Kongress kennen, also die einfach die
Die Strukturen da kennen, die äh ja, also die sich zwar auch jedes Jahr erstmal wieder an das neue Raumlayout gewöhnen müssen, aber die, die in etwa wissen, wie äh das tickt.
Ja? Und diese sagen können, hier guck mal, ich zeige dir mal, wie hier irgendwie das Engel äh Subsystem vor sich,
pulsiert. So was ist einfach echt super interessant, so ein bisschen auch so ein so ein Backstage äh äh Blick auf äh den Kongress zu werfen, ja. Also nicht äh wir sitzen heute bei einer halben Stunde am Tisch der Projektleitung, aber so einfach,
begreiflich machen, wie dieser Organismus,
das das muss super spannend sein, weiß ich nicht, mal gucken. Vielleicht habe ich ja auch noch Zeit über.
Genau, also wer, wer da, wer das, wer das.
Zweifel das. Ja haben wir.
Stürzen muss. Jetzt haben wir lange genug dafür geworben. Jetzt werbe ich für meine Vorträge. Ich werde äh auch einen Vortrag halten beim Kongress,
und ich werde auch einen Workshop machen und ich werde auch noch bei einem noch einem Vortrag mit dabei sein.
Das war eins mehr als ich.
Äh es gibt einen einmal den Vortrag mit dem wohlklingenden Namen Bullshit made in Germany,
und dann den äh CCC Jahresrückblick, den ich dieses Jahr wahrscheinlich mitgestalten werde,
und äh dann noch eine kleine Sache so zu GSM Hacking, die ich dann im Workshop eher wahrscheinlich machen werde als im Vortrag.
Ja, also Freunde, äh gebt euch einen Ruck, kommt dahin, bis jetzt hat's, glaube ich, nie jemand bereut und dieses äh Patinnensystem äh wird euch da ein, ein geschmeidiges äh ein geschmeidiges Abdriften,
in das Leben erleichtern, indem ihr jedes Jahr schon vorher wisst, dass ihr vom siebenundzwanzigsten bis dreißigsten nicht,
Verfügung steht für irgendwas außer den Kongress der Chaoten aus dem Computerclub.
Genau und ich mache ich äh werde eine ein berufen. Genau.
Wird wird Podcast mit Zuschauern.
Genau, das ist dann das Sendezentrum. Also das Handy ist halt auch wirklich jetzt so Hacking, ne, also hier geht's wirklich um,
Nee, eben nicht so wie letztes Jahr, weil letztes Jahr hatten wir das nicht. Also es gab nicht so.
Hast doch den Erik da die ganze Zeit geknechtet, der hat doch da hunderttausend Zeilen Code produziert. Willst du da nicht erzählen, dass das nicht.
Es hieß nicht offiziell, es war vielleicht eine Bitterversion davon, aber äh diesmal ist das Peitschen knallen deutlich äh organisierter, ja.
Stimmen sie mit ein in den Tax der Arbeit. Nein nein. Äh das soll halt einfach so ein,
Treffpunkt sein für ähm auch für Podcaster vor allem, die halt dort,
andocken sollen und das soll halt so ein, ein, ein Space rund um diese ganze Szene äh sein und,
Radio machen, selber aufnehmen am Tisch, äh dem live Event folgen und eben auch die Hackerei, all das zusammen soll da äh wirken und ich plane auch noch einen Workshop dazu zu machen,
Ja und ansonsten bin ich nur für die Eröffnung zuständig.
Das hast du jetzt schon verraten. Ich dachte, das wäre geheim. Weiß ich nicht. Bis jetzt ist sowieso alles geheim, weil der Fahrplan noch nicht wirklich öffentlich ist,
Okay, also.
Jetzt auch nicht so ein besonderes Ding.
Genug der Werbung für diese Veranstaltung. Sie wird jetzt eh von japanischen Touristenscharen überrannt werden, die die Chaospartinnen fotografieren, dann werden wir uns noch überlegen, dass das 'ne scheiß.
Ach du meinst der Kongress kommt dann demnächst äh äh so in die in die Reisekataloge, ja. Auf der Tourismusbörse wird Hamburg damit so, ja und über neue Jahr können sie ja auch eins dieser abgefahrenen Hacker Events echte Nerds zum.
Pro Tipp, pro Tipp im Planet, ne?
Reservieren Sie früh die Chaos-Patinnen sind meist schon im November ausgebucht. Plätze sind heiß begehrt.
Oh Mann, du hast Zeit für uns hier äh ans Ende zu kommen. Findest du nicht auch?
Ja, total schon längst. So, auf Wiederhören. So, Feierabend.
Tschüss, was?